in this video i'm going to break down
how i learned how to consistently
generate leads independent of platforms
and the key piece that i was missing in
multiple different platforms i'm going
to tell you five key stories throughout
my life that massively impacted how
effective my marketing was as a result
of the exchange and if you don't know
who i am my name is alex mosey i'm a
business investor and i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that's about 85 million a year
and i have nothing to sell you i have no
courses no masterminds no mentorships i
make these videos have to document the
lessons that i've had and hopefully make
sure that the pain that i suffered on
the way here was not in vain so if
you're new to mozi nation welcome and
enjoy the video in this video i'm gonna
walk you through why you are probably
not getting the results that you wish
you were from what you are doing one of
the most misunderstood concepts that
create success in some people and
failure without understanding why in
most others all right and it really all
underpins volume so let's dive in so a
few high level observations before i
dive into this the first thing is uh
there's a setting in our community
called do the boring work and a lot of
times we don't confront the work that we
that must be done because it's not
exciting or sexy and it feels somehow
like it's beneath us you know
prospecting and doing 100 a day can feel
tedious you know posting and repurposing
the same content across lots of
different media sources can feel tedious
you know reaching out to people you know
and asking if they know someone who
might be interested in your products or
services might feel tedious or creating
you know 100 different ad variations
with different hooks and headlines can
seem tedious it's very easy to
understand very hard to do mostly
because people don't have the discipline
and the work ethic to go through the
boring work which kind of leads to the
second one here which is that uh there's
a saying between my my closest friend
and i dr cashy uh violence is the answer
uh sometimes when you have this outcome
that you must achieve in your life
because of the goals and insecurities
that we have set upon ourselves uh that
just being violent with the level of
activity that we are doing ultimately
get us much closer than uh you know the
nuances and the skill that sometimes we
like to project and pretend matter more
than just physically doing a sheer
higher volume of work number three is
that if you do more than you are doing
right now you will get more than you
currently have and that is a promise and
you can take that to the bank and number
four is do what matters most first so
right now you probably have lots of
things that you know fill up your day in
the morning all that kind of stuff but
the things there are only four
activities that will actually generate
more business for you period that is new
all right number one is reaching out to
people you know number two is posting to
an audience that you know number three
is reaching out to people who don't know
one-on-one and number four is
advertising right those are the four
only four ways you can get new clients
and so if you're not doing one of those
four things and you're struggling to get
customers you're not doing lots of those
four things as your primary activities
then that is probably one of the reasons
that you don't have the amount of
customers that you wish you had all
right and so what i want to do is take
this quick moment to introduce an
equation that i've thought a lot about
but it's v times s times d so volume
time scale times time and this is a kind
of a flywheel that feeds itself and
which and i'll get to the actual like
wording behind this but essentially the
more volume to do the better you are at
it and longer you do it the more
throughput you will ultimately have the
more outcome the more clients the more
sales the more leads you will ultimately
have from doing it all right so let's
dive into this in a little bit more so
in other words and this is based on just
like pure foundational principles of
logic right the more we do the better we
get the better we get the more we do
because we like it because we're better
at it right and the longer we do
something the better we get the better
we get the longer we do it right and
i'll show you a couple examples
in some of the stories and examples i
have today that will show you how
compounding massively affected my life
and so in this way each of these three
variables volume skill and time feed
each other but it all starts with doing
and so these are the three we're going
to focus just on volume today because i
want to be mindful of your time and so
i'll tell you a quick example of this so
i um when i this is probably a decade
ago i was starting my gym which is the
first business i own a real business
that i own someone's like oh you should
run flyers and i was like okay cool so i
went out i did you know a bunch of
flyers it you know it didn't really work
for me and so you know a few months
later i was talking to a friend of mine
who had you know multiple successful
locations he was doing well and um i was
like hey uh you know i did he's like you
should do flyers and i was like nah i
did that it didn't work for me he's like
well you know what what was your what
was your test size and i was like test
size what do you mean he was like well
how many did you test before you you
know scaled it up and i was like well i
mean i put 300 out and he was like 300.
like total and i was like well yeah he's
like i don't he's like i don't even test
for less than 5 000 flyers and all of a
sudden i was like whoa he's like yeah
he's like i'll put out a hundred
thousand flyers a month he's like and
i'll get a half a percent or a percent
back he's like who walked through the
door he's like yeah but 100 000 flyers a
percent back i get 30 people a day
walking in my store and i was like holy
cow my understanding of the sheer volume
for the activity that i thought wasn't
working was just dramatically under what
it really was supposed to be and in that
moment i had a belief broken about what
volume really means this happens all the
time and i'll tell you a couple other
examples in a second but like this
happens all the time even in like
fitness stuff people are like man why
can't i get jacked and i'm like uh you
know why can't i grow my arms it's like
all right well how many sets of arms are
you doing every week and they're like
well i train arms twice a week i'm like
what are you doing they're like well you
know like three sets of ten and i'm like
that's it like per week like so six
total sets they're like yeah i'm like
well try 12 sets six days a week and i
guarantee your arms will grow they're
like seriously i'm like yeah imagine
that the more you do the more you look
like you can do so i'll give you a
different one that i had this isn't a in
a paid ads example which is similar to
flyers just a different platform i had a
an agency owner who was walking who's
talking to us in within our software
company and he was like hey you know my
lead flow's stalling out i can't seem to
scale above a certain amount you know
it's like okay well you know how many
pieces of creative are you putting out
you know uh per week and he was like
he confidently answered right so he was
like he's like oh he's like that we have
on point he's like we're putting out
like five to ten pieces of content a
week and i was like per week he was like
yeah and i was like dude and i scrolled
over i shared my screen of my creative
department and i was like we're testing
30 pieces every three days he was like
what i was like yeah
it's level of output quantity of output
the level like
most people dramatically underestimate
how much work it takes to make money
right the thing is is once you
understand and for most people and this
is the point that i'm hoping somebody
who's like hasn't gotten their first
customer or wants to start on a new
channel if you already have one working
is you usually need to do a lot more
because your s in that equation your
skill level is low and you have no time
that has compounded for you so you must
compensate with extraordinary volume so
that you can learn the skill and then
begin the compounding process that will
give you the throughput or outcome that
you desire and so a lot of times you got
to do a lot more in the beginning to get
the ball rolling all right and when i
was talking to grant about his uh his
overarching content strategy i was like
hey man you know how many pieces what's
the framework that you use and he was
like bro and this is actually this was
in a different call i had with him
that's not not on the channel he's like
bro if someone's trying to sell you a
framework he's like they're just trying
to sell you something he's like it's
about 10x and he said that
he wasn't saying it in a in a pejorative
way he meant it genuinely he's like dude
he's like we just take massive action
he's like we just try and be omnipresent
he's like look at your instagram look at
my scripts we pulled both of them up and
he's like i'm posting six times a day
he's like i'm posting 15 times a day on
twitter and she's like you just pulled
up every one of them compared them to
mine he's like he's like i'm just doing
way more than you and i was like man and
he's been doing it for 10 years longer
right and so that was a huge epiphany
for me and then for me i i switch from
one time a week to one times a day and
here's what's crazy my growth
organically 40xed from a 7x increase in
effort so there is a multiplicative
effect here because sure we did more but
we got better at the doing and then the
more we did the more each of those other
pieces fed one another right and so
again all of this starts with the doing
and taking a lot more than most people
anticipate to get the result and get
going and so this is a different nuance
on volume this is more level of effort
but i think it bears mentioning because
for this concept to kind of sink in i
want to hit it from a couple different
angles so this is the number one video
or at this time is one of the number one
videos on the channel and i made this
like a month ago and i i realized that
quality most times trumps quantity right
and the thing is but quality and
quantity trumps just quantity right or
just quality and so this particular
piece of content took me 20 hours to
actually put the slide deck together and
then two days of travel to go film and
then go lo and behold it ends up being
you know the number one thing on there
and to me i was like well that's not
really surprising i spent a ton of time
on this and so it was just and like i'm
just saying i get reminded of this at
all levels of the game you know what i
mean and so i'm making these videos
because like as i'm learning it i'm
sharing it um so that hopefully it
provides some value to you like
it just takes a lot more work than most
people think like layla this is four or
five years ago when we were re-filming
an entire content portal so she had
probably recorded god i don't know 70 or
so videos with you know trainings and
everything and she got done and she was
like i don't think these are that good
and she was and i was like it's like
she's like i just i don't know i don't
know if they're like hitting the way i
want them to be they're like just not as
crisp and we sat there and and i was
like
i'll do them again she looked at me and
she was like yeah you're right
because the thing is is like and i've
said this before and i'll keep saying it
like your work works on you more than
you work on it the thing we are
developing is our character because
that's the ultimate prize that we get at
the end of the race right we can't keep
the stuff that we have with us and so
we're doing this work to become better
people right and so if you do it again
it's no it's nothing bad about it you're
just like cool i get more practice at
doing the thing and my s is going to get
better in the throughput equation so
even if you did the same in terms of
volume of output the skill on the
equation the s is going to be higher so
you're still going to actually still get
more throughput even if you do the same
effort again right and so that's why the
level of effort and in
giving a [ __ ] for lack of a retirement
really working like violence is the
answer doing the boring work and putting
the time under the bar in to use a
fitness analogy um is is what is
required and most people dramatically
underestimate the volume all right and
so i'm going to tell you this last one
to wrap this wrap this little uh
piece up which is i wrote this book
right it took me basically like a year
to write it it took me two weeks to
write it took me a year to edit it and
right now i get dms every day like when
is the second book coming out and so
right now i'm on the fifth version of
book two end to end i had to completely
copy copy right
edited from a professional editor and
that was version one and i've since made
four more versions since then but the
thing is is the difference between that
level of effort is why
many times i think things don't work out
is that most people put like a seven out
of ten effort or an eight out of ten
effort and then look at somebody who put
a 10 out of 10 effort in and think well
i didn't put that much less effort in
but you don't realize the difference
between an eight and a 10 might be five
times the work but also the difference
between an eight and a ten might be a
hundred times the outcome and so the
actual net outcome on the incremental
increase in work is still worth it
that's what's crazy is that if it takes
five times the effort to go from an
eight to a ten you might get a hundred
times even though you only did five
times more work and so this is one of
these beliefs that i i've ingrained in
myself within how we do business but i'm
sharing it with you because most things
that most people make suck most products
suck most marketing sucks most
businesses suck and most people suck at
the things that they think they're good
at right and it's because they don't
even know how to work they don't even
know how to do it and i'll tell you this
final story to wrap this up when i was a
legal intern in a in a past lifetime at
a chemical company called arkema in
france believe it or not i worked there
in the legal department and this older
more experienced you know senior lawyer
at the firm
in the department kind of like tapped i
was like oh i'm going to go back to work
and she like tapped my shoulder and she
was like you don't even know how to work
and i was like what do you mean and she
was like you're so young she's like you
don't even know
what work really is and it and it just
hit me and it struck me like to my core
because i was like how can she tell me
that i don't know how to work but here i
am 10 years 15 years later and i think
to myself like man i had no idea what
work even looked like because i don't
even know how to focus the way i do now
i didn't know how to eliminate
distractions i didn't know what it
looked like to just put rep after rep
after rep after rep in to just get that
thing just right the beautiful thing
especially when it comes to marketing
stuff is that when you make those each
of those posts each of those outreaches
each of those calls each of those ads
that you run make you better they
increase the s and so in that way the v
the s and the t the volume the skill and
the time work on each other and then
yields you a higher throughput because
they are multiplicative not additive and
that's like the one thing that if i can
drive this home is that most people just
do so much less volume than they think
because and then they look at the the
vehicle that they're using and think why
is this not working when the reality was
that you were not working because you
did not know how much work really was
required to get to where you wanted to
go and so um with that in other words
most times you just need to do more than
what you're currently doing and a lot
more of it okay so if you don't uh know
me like i said my name is alex ramose i
own acquisition.com we're business
investors our portfolio does about 85
million dollars a year and i have
nothing to sell you if you enjoyed this
video watch another one and lots of love
either way mozzie nation keep rockin